[Music]
denied their money and their savings
these people say they are faced with no
choice but to keep protesting it's been
two years since lebanon's banks insisted
money could only be withdrawn in the
local currency the lira
it is at a much lower rate than the
market which means they lose 70 percent
of its value it's a process now known as
lirification
changing the deposits into lira it will
take us to a hyper and hyper inflation
this is very bad to the lebanese economy
the financial system collapsed in late
2019
successive governments had piled up debt
for years before money stopped coming in
the
banking system the central bank and the
lebanese state were literally embedded
together uh as a result uh this
excessive consumerist economic model was
financed through deposits through the
deposits from the wealthy diaspora
community which the banks then use to
lend to the central bank now the state
is nearly bankrupt and banks are
insolvent authorities have not agreed on
the way out of the crisis but they
acknowledge lyrification is possible but
at the rate that dominates trading
clarification is one of the things that
it is mentioned from now and then
makes it very difficult in order uh to
say exactly when they will take back the
deposit as far as i know prime minister
miati is doing his best in order the
small and the the middle depositor to
receive back their deposits
many are skeptical
protests like this one have not brought
change the state is still controlled by
the same political class blamed for the
financial collapse and those who hold
the power and the individuals linked to
them are the majority of shareholders
and banks
depositors say it is they who have been
bearing the losses in the financial
sector officials estimate amount to 69
billion dollars we're seeing uh also
like taxes increase taxes on people
meanwhile like the majority of the
people get get paid and live in east
europe which has lost around 95 of its
value
politicians should be presenting an
economic recovery plan to the
international monetary fund to receive
assistance but that would require
reforms that weaken their hold on the
state's resources
instead they prepared a state budget
that appears to put additional burdens
on the people while protecting their own
financial interests senator al-jazeera
beirut